tutti ragazzi e benvenute questo nuovo
video io sono fa vj e oggi siamo su su
motori dreams dopo non so neanche quanto
tempo dall'ultimo episodio di sui motori
siano passati anni se per caso qualcuno
avrebbe trovato delle mappe nuove che
non aveva ancora fatto sarei tornato su
su motori ed effettivamente da quando ho
fatto quel blog mi avete contattato in
400 mandandomi praticamente un pacchetto
di 40 mappe siete stati in tantissimi a
mandar melo e quindi niente dato che
queste mappe ancora non lo fate dire che
si può fare un altro episodio su motori
quindi direi di finire la premessa
secolare come al solito enti reti
cominciare questi episodi su motori lui
prevedo sarà un qualcosa di fantastico
quindi iniziamo con le prima mappa preso
c'è non sanno che cos'è sta roba ma
sembra un tempio maya una roba del
genere bravi inchinatevi afa vj tutti
quanti se come ti sei permesso come chi
sei per mac bastardo non si spinge al re
non si spinge allora facciamo braccio di
ferro fermo qua fermo braccio di ferro
che cazzo fai ti tiri indietro ma
all'inizio
cosa fa ma non potevi semplicemente dire
no non lo voglio fare non ti devi
suicidare per forza mio addio ragazzi
cioè va bene partiamo benissimo a tutti
che assiste decidano bene così alla
forse non ci siamo capiti dovete
inchinarmi come si deve
bravo biancobù famila para cos'è cosa va
e cosa fa raga marrone
ma ora che a dire di cambiare perché
sono 40 i livelli non so come gioca mi
ricordo le mappe vecchie di su motori
avevo paura di giocare non sapevo cosa
mi trovavo davanti
cos'è sta roba chiediamo picchiare il
suo una donna il verde è morto è morto
non può essere vivo ancora non ci credo
che cazzo successo sarà chiesto a
livello non ha senso come che stanno
facendo due bianco stanno ingrossando a
vicente ragazzi io non vi abbiamo sto
livello perché non l'ho capito adesso
vado a dare aiutare verde ti salvo io ti
salvo io mica morto di nuovo
raga non ce la faremo cosa impazzita la
trave non ce la faremo mai ci provo
l'ultima volta il marrone di tranquillo
tanto non viene demolito perché non
andiamo sul marrone cioè stavolta
andiamo su di lui che sta bello
tranquillo
ok non è caduto il ponte noi cazzo
invece mi è caduto resto tra marrone mi
sono sempre chiesto chi la concepisce
ste mappe perché non ho la più pallida
idea c'è un gong lo sono io lo sono io
lo sono io lo sono io
state lontani dal miur gonzo il mio gong
figli de na [ __ ] era mio il gong
bastardi che è successo dovevo soltanto
suonarlo maledetti neanche quello mi
fate fare neanche quello grazie grazie
chi perde molo massacro set meriti come
cazzo fatto mela segno sta cosa del gong
maledetti tutti mela segno cos'è un
domino questo un occhio e figo ragazzi è
un domino fantastico stai mese il
tappeto rosso per faringei bravi così
adesso ci passa un attimo
togliti maledetto il tappeto è mio
ragazzi ho rotto il domino bene così
cosa dice che non doveva addio
[Musica]
io sono ready su motori al centro il
marchio il tappeto madonna che ubriaco
ragazzi e non so che cosa sta un certo
punto esplodono non si sa perché e io mi
sento che cazzo cos'è
guardate che vado a rare in più cos'è
sta roba su motori mi sta stupendo
sempre di più non so dove dovremmo
arrivare prima o poi comunque va beh io
io mi sta sempre più sul culo al verde
alla fine c'è sempre lui il mio nemico
numero uno non troverò mai la
motivazione di richiami su sto gioco
credetevi cos'è sta roba
questa è pazzia pozzi a questa è sporta
ma che cazzo fanno in due
la t shirt cos'è sta roba dobbiamo
dobbiamo andare lì dentro
palla in buca ma lo ha fatto cazzo ma
che mappa ecco resta il qual è lo scopo
lista ma fa parte prendersi un pallone
di 4 metri nel deretano
[Musica]
ci prova il potere di matrix e dentro di
me
riso one questa è una verità di cosa sia
vado sempre con tre giocatori alla fine
ma la murgia giocata questa se me la
ricordo
erano i primi episodi tra l'altro se non
proprio il primo cioè mio dio
il chi la fa vj the king inchinatevi
devo riuscire a fare come nel primo
episodio ma la ricordo questa devo
riuscire a pestare brutto stronzo grande
crosetta crollando alzati maledizione
non inglobati il verde non serve adesso
alzati qualcuno ci aiuti barone pezzotti
to salvami salumi maledizione che non ha
senso sono morto schierarsi grazie per
l'aiuto grazie mille
bravo verde scatenati come una vacca il
calore
[Musica]
gara solo una birra parte tutte e tre
con potute se è così marrone cosi
capisci che il migliore adesso medium
questo mi incuriosisce perché cos'è
questo non stadio
questo dovrebbe essere uno stadio di
cosa uno stadio con un palo in mezzo che
razza di gioco è il mio zio cos'è sono
anche per uno stadio esplosivo bene
grazie
cosa sta facendo il bianco bene così la
ragazzi voglio fare una cosa troppo
epica togliti dai cazzo marrone togliti
che già sono ubriaco di mio togli do il
mio dio ragazzi no no no bianca non ti
avvicinare al palo
molti amici dell'albaro stavo detto di
non toccare il palo siamo all'ultima
mappa ragazzi ma prima di concludere
vorrei fare una mappa che è rimasta
nella storia di su motori chi ha visto
le episodi precedenti ha di sicuro di
che cosa sto parlando
signori e signori sacra e la mappa
ragazzi è la mia preferita in assoluto
vai verde dai dimostrazione ok perfetto
mi sono su molecola tu che cazzo faccio
raga sto perdendo una gamba mi sa che ho
perso tutto verde il tuo momento puoi
tornare a splendere dopo mesi di
inattività bravo così cosa fa il marrone
ragazzi che cazzo sta facendo il marrone
cosa fa
va bene
non si sa per questa mappa e così è
normale state tranquilli ragazzi mi sa
che il verde su dimenticato come quali
salti epici di una volta quindi direi
che posso concludere qui seguito è
piaciuto come al solito
lasciate un commento mi piace anche alla
pagina di facebook che come noi video
trovate la descrizione se non siete
ancora iscritti iscrivetevi noi ci
rivediamo in un prossimo video belle
ragazze
[Musica]